how many times have you been on the
internet and noticed creepy ads that are
tailored to your internet search history
or speaking of search history how many
times you've been on the internet and
worried about somebody perhaps
even your government tracking the
websites that you visit well fortunately
today's video is sponsored by nordvpn
which is helping to give internet users
all the tricks and tools of a proper
21st century online experience you might
have heard me talk about what nordvpn
can do for you previously encrypt your
internet data move your online activity
to another location with just one click
either for superior security or new
streaming options and all of that still
true nordvpn has more than 5 000 servers
spread throughout 60 countries but vpns
give you access to so many more options
than just new tv shows have trouble
connecting to social media where you
live nordvpn want to buy a movie that's
cheaper somewhere else or maybe not
available in your country at all nordvpn
want to route your connection through
multiple servers just for extra
protection absolutely with nordvpn you
can do it all and that includes
utilizing their threat protection
upgrade which blocks ads eradicates web
trackers checks for malware and more
right as part of a unique deal you guys
can get a two-year plan at a huge
discount plus an additional four months
for free but if you do try nord and
change your mind there's a 30-day
money-back guarantee all you've got to
do is go to nordvpn.com bio again that's
nordvpn.com bio for a two-year deal at a
huge discount plus four free months on
top of that as a bonus or just follow
the link in the description box below
and now today's video
three-time pulitzer prize-winning
journalist arthur crock described joseph
pulitzer as having a shining personal
character humility in possession of
power and compassion for the unfortunate
he hated cant sham injustice and
corruption and was incapable of any of
these other people describe joseph
pulitzer as the greatest journalist on
earth or the most interesting man on the
planet his life was said to resemble a
story out of the books of giants goblins
and fairies for many contemporaries
joseph pulitzer was the perfect example
of the american dream he was an
immigrant who came to america all alone
with no money and without even speaking
the language but he worked hard all day
every day and he made something of
himself becoming one of the most
influential voices in the country his
story was a refreshing change of pace
from most other businessmen of his era
who inherited fortunes and enlarged them
through dishonest underhanded even
fraudulent means but pulitzer himself
was hardly innocent in their pursuit of
success his newspapers chased
sensationalism sex scandal murder and
fear-mongering while qualities such as
fairness accuracy and accountability
were often left by the wayside this
approach which became known as yellow
journalism has infected almost every
facet of the fourth estate and is still
of course
prevalent today
[Music]
joseph pulitzer was born on april 10
1847 in the town of maiko in
southeastern hungary the second of four
children to philip pulitzer a successful
magyar jewish grain dealer and louise
berger a catholic austro-german by 1853
philip pulitzer had made enough money
from the grain business to retire and
move his family to budapest he later
died of heart disease when joseph was 11
years old a few years later joseph's
mother got remarried to a businessman
named max blau who developed a hostile
relationship with his step-children we
don't know specifics about what happened
we just know that pulitzer hated blau
and couldn't wait to leave home when
joseph reached that dreaded stage of
puberty he shot up like a bean pole as a
teenager he was about 1.9 meters tall at
6 foot 3 in freedom units but he was
very skinny to the point where he always
looked ill and emaciated this proved to
be a problem when the 17 year old
pulitzer tried to enlist in the austrian
army hoping to follow in the footsteps
of two uncles who were both officers
unfortunately joseph was told that he
was too gaunt too young and his eyesight
was too bad so he was rejected
undeterred bullets had traveled to paris
looking to join the french foreign
legion but they too gave him the same
answer he then went to london hoping
that he might get sent to india but was
rejected again after that came hamburg
where pulitzer tried his luck as a
sailor but still no go for a while it
looked like no one was desperate enough
to accept this near-sighted skinny
hungarian kid but fortunately for joseph
while in hamburg he run into recruiting
agents for the american union army these
agents received bounties for every
soldier they signed so they were ready
to take anyone willing to put their mark
on the dotted line and there was in 1864
that joseph pulitzer packed up his
things and went aboard a rickety ship
that crossed the atlantic crammed with a
throng of immigrants looking to make it
big in america while docking into boston
harbor pulitzer jumped overboard into
the cold water swammed ashore and
traveled to new york alone by train he
did all of this so that he could collect
the 300 enlisting bounty himself on
november 12 1864 pulitzer made it to
remount camp in maryland where he joined
the l company of the first new york
lincoln cavalry although he only ever
took part in a few minor skirmishes he
was quickly disabused of whatever
glamorous notions of the military life
he might have gained from his uncles his
captain took an instant dislike to him
due to his weak scarecrow-like
constitution and heavily accented broken
english the other soldiers followed
their captain's queue and mocked the new
recruit instead of calling him pulitzer
they called him pulitzer and considered
it an invitation to grab joseph's
prodigious nose so once the war was over
what was next for young joseph
definitely not a military career that
much was clear he was broke sleeping on
the streets of new york the city saw a
large influx of veterans so finding any
kind of job was difficult pulitzer spoke
almost no english but was fluent in
french and german so he thought he would
move to a place with a large german
population he sold his last worldly
possession a white silk handkerchief and
used the money to buy food and a ticket
to st louis
in october 1865 pulitzer arrived at his
new home at first he was desperate for
any kind of work that he could get he
served as a coal shoveler than a mule
caretaker a stevedore a laborer a
deckhand and a waiter all of them were
dead-end jobs that paid chicken feed so
pulitz had to work two jobs at a time 16
hours a day just to barely make ends
meet plus another four hours spent at
the library learning english the
librarian there udo bach vogel became
his first friend in america and helped
pulitzer learn the language by carrying
out conversations in english one day
pulitzer and 40 other people got scammed
by a con artist who promised them great
jobs on our plantation in louisiana the
marks paid him five dollars and then
they boarded a steamboat that simply
dumped them in a remote area about 40
miles from louis apparently it took them
three days without food or water to make
it back to the city it was an awful
ordeal but for joseph pulitzer it turned
out to be the best thing that ever
happened to him a local reporter heard
the story track down pulitzer and
convinced him to write an account of the
experience for the german language
newspaper wesley post he did well enough
that the editor asked him to keep
writing immediately pulitzer discovered
that he had a knack for journalism but
the sparse assignments weren't enough to
pay rent fortunately for him at the
newspaper building he made the
acquaintance of two lawyers who got him
a record-keeping job with the atlanta
and pacific railroad as it turned out
pulitzer had a knack for that as well
the attorneys encouraged him to enter
law school and even gave him free access
to the library so that he could study at
his leisure now a few noteworthy things
happened in the years that followed
josephus became an american citizen his
younger brother albert joined him in
saint louis and became a german teacher
and pulitzer always admitted to the bar
and he became a notary public his new
career however wasn't a hit joseph still
struggled with english he didn't have
money to spend on smart looking clothes
his odd scruffy appearance didn't
attract many customers and he gave up
the exhilarating life of a notary public
but the timing worked out great because
the west lick post was looking for a new
full-time reporter
and he got the job pulitzer was a
complete workaholic he routinely worked
16 hours a day chasing down every lead
and questioning every person with
unbridled enthusiasm his editors loved
him but his fellow journalists resented
him for making them look bad on more
than one occasion pulitzer was sent out
on a wild goose chase but this never
dampened his spirit his entry into the
world of politics was just as
serendipitous pulitzer joined the
republican party like many of his
newspaper colleagues on december 14 1869
he attended a republican meeting as a
reporter they needed to put forward a
candidate for the missouri state
legislature because everyone thought
that the democrats had the election in
the bag someone nominated pulitzer as a
joke the rest of the crowd laughed and
unanimously selected pulitzer as their
candidates guess what
he won pulitzer put the same amount of
effort into his election race as he did
into his reporting he campaigned in the
streets he visited people at home and
displayed a genuine enthusiasm that
struck a chord with the voters
technically the moment pulitzer took his
seat he was breaking the law because he
was three years too young to serve in
the legislature if anyone realized this
they kept it quiet and pulitzer served
out his term illegally his most notable
contribution was voting to support the
15th amendment which gave black men the
right to vote pulitzers are the
highlight from his time as state
legislature generated a lot more
headlines though it was a rivalry
between him and a democratic opponent
named captain edward augustine which
culminated in a fight inside the lobby
of schmidt's hotel in jefferson city
where pulitzer pulled a gun and shot
augustine twice what exactly happened
has never been made clear since
newspapers told different versions based
on whom they supported they all agreed
that augustine taunted and insulted
pulitzer several times but the pro
pulitzer papers said that augustine was
armed and charging at his enemy when
pulitzer shot him in self-defense while
the pro-augustine camp claimed that
pulitzer shot an unarmed man ultimately
pulitzer was charged with assault with
intent to kill he was even found guilty
but he was let go with only a 405 fine
[Music]
after his term was done pulitzer
remained involved in politics but grew
increasingly disillusioned with the
republican party pulitzer was the kind
of man who would never put party over
principles so when he perceived that the
republicans were showing signs of
corruption or incompetence he distanced
himself from them for a while pulitzer
joined the short-lived liberal
republican party which opposed ulysses s
grant's presidential nomination and
instead campaigned for new york tribune
founder horace greeley for bullet sir
the last draw came when the republican
party backed rutherford b hayes
president during the 1876 election he
switched to the democrats and began
campaigning for new york governor samuel
jones tilden pulitzer was so firing and
passion whenever he spoke in public that
during one speech at the cooper union in
new york he burst a blood vessel and
started coughing up blood halfway
through but he still finished his talk
in front of a standing room only
audience pulitzer had another close call
on his 30th birthday when the hotel he
was staying in court fire the alarm
wasn't working so many of the residents
were only made aware of the fire by the
frantic screaming and chaos that was
happening outside seventeen people
perished in the blaze and pulitzer
himself was almost among them before
being rescued but let's take the bad
with the good soon after the fire
pulitzer moved to washington dc where he
fell in love with 23 year old kate davis
the two got married on june 19 1878 and
went on to have seven children together
all the while he was involved in
politics pulitzer never abandoned
journalism his dream was to have his own
newspaper but he wasn't exactly rolling
in dough yet in late 1878 he learned
that the st louis dispatch was up for
sale after going bankrupt pulitzer only
had around five thousand dollars to
spend so to prevent any outside interest
he sent a covert emissary to bid on his
behalf and managed to buy it for half of
his budget more good news followed
because the publisher of one of the
newspaper's main rivals the st louis
post called up to offer a merger because
he didn't want to compete and thus at 31
years old joseph pulitzer owned his
first newspaper the saint louis
post-dispatch the paper circulation
steadily rose under pulitzer's
leadership and became one of saint
louis's main political voices usually
staying true to pulitzer's pledge that
the post in dispatch will serve no party
but the people immediately he started a
fight with the bigger more established
missouri republican which despite its
misleading name was published by
democrat william hyde and we guess it
was opposite day and sunday lewis when
they named their newspapers because
another one of pulitzer's competitors
was the globe democrat which you guessed
it was actually a republican newspaper
pulitzer's aggressive tactics of picking
fights with virtually every other print
publication in the city brought new
readers to the post dispatch besides
politicians pulitzer also crusaded
against a lottery rack at a horse car
monopoly and the gas company and this
was just in the first few months in a
short time pulitzer had made quite a few
enemies so he got into the habit of
walking around with a pistol so did his
editor john cockerell and he actually
had a chance to use it in 1882 there was
an election to fill the seat of deceased
congressman thomas allen the democrats
backed a lawyer named james broadhead
but pulitzer strongly opposed him
consequently broadhead became the
post-dispatcher's new prime target
broadhead himself didn't respond to the
attacks but his friend and law partner
alonso slayback did on october 13th
slayback charged into the offices of the
post-dispatched and launched a virulent
and threatening terrain cockerel in
return the editor opened his desk drawer
pulled out his gun and fired killing
slayback almost instantly the story
became a big sensation newspaper
employees testified that slayback had a
gun in his hand and was aiming it when
cockerell opened fire other papers
however were giddy with the excitement
and the opportunity of taking down the
post dispatch and many of them portrayed
slayback as an innocent unarmed man who
was murdered in cold blood at one point
the missouri republican whipped up its
readers into such a frenzy that a mob
formed outside the officers of the post
dispatch looking to burn the whole place
down ultimately cockerell was exonerated
during his trial but the court's public
opinion wasn't as merciful the
circulation of the post dispatch
plummeted advertisers left in droves
pulitzer's personal reputation took a
big hit and his family became socially
ostracized he felt like maybe it was
time for a change
the aftermath following slayback's death
took its toll not only on pulitzer's
business but also on his health in the
spring of 1883 joseph and his wife
traveled to new york intent on going on
a long european vacation to rest up
however while in new york pulitzer heard
that infamous robber baron jay gould was
looking to sell his newspaper the new
york world for years pulitzer dreamt of
running a publication in the big apple
so he entered negotiations with gould
and on may 10 1883 joseph pulitzer
bought the new york world for 346 000
just like the post dispatch pulitzer
announced in the first issue under his
ownership that from then on the new york
world would be dedicated to the cause of
the people rather than the purse of the
potentates will expose all fraud and
sham fight all public evils and abusers
and serve and battle for the people with
earnest sincerity basically pulitzer
wanted his newspaper to be aimed at
immigrants and the working class he knew
this was the strategy that brought them
to the dance and he had no reason to
switch it up now most of new york's
politicians and businessmen became equal
opportunity targets including the
world's former owner jay gould there was
a rumor going around that gould remained
a secret partner in the newspaper
pulitzer feared this would ruin his
champion of the underdog credential so
he made sure that gould bore the brunt
of his literary attacks just to show
that the two were not on the same side
not that cool didn't deserve it though
in fact we've made a video about him a
while back you can check that out if you
want to know more about all the
shenanigans that he got up to
there were many as a consequence of
focusing on the common man the newspaper
began covering a lot more human interest
stories at first these were only present
in the sunday edition which pulitzer
used as a sort of testing ground for his
new ideas it featured stories about
cannibalism at sea crazy religious sects
human sacrifice in the united states and
of course murder after gruesome murder
one particularly infamous headline even
read french socialist and explorer
discovers a race of savages with
well-developed tales it didn't take
pulitzer long to realize that the more
lurid scandalous or violent the story
was the more copies it sold soon enough
such accounts made their way from the
sunday edition into the weekday papers
the new york world became the progenitor
of the tabloids of today where
sensationalism scandal and
fear-mongering triumphed over fairness
accuracy and integrity but it wasn't all
bad to be fair the world had its moments
it exposed many tales of fraud and
corruption both in the public and
private sectors it recruited intrepid
journalists who conducted genuine
investigations the most famous of all
being nellie bly it organized stunts and
promotions that ultimately benefited
society even though their main goal was
to sell newspaper subscriptions the most
memorable one involved raising funds to
build a gigantic pedestal in new york
harbor for the statue of liberty neither
congress nor new york governor grover
cleveland wanted to pony up the doe so
it's entirely possible that without
pulitzer's help the statue of liberty
might have been shipped back to france
[Music]
pulitzer's hard work aggression and
sensationalism turns the new york world
into the best-selling newspaper in
america and him into a rich man but the
effort took its toll on his body
remember that he was never really the
picture of health plus he worked himself
ragged 12 to 16 hour days for most of
his adult life add to that the stress of
his job and joseph pulitzer had become a
frail and sickly man even though he was
only in his early 40s his asthma was
getting worse his eyesight was almost
gone his nerves were shattered and he
developed an extreme sensitivity to
noise so much so that he had to
soundproof the rooms where he spent most
of his time pulitzer spent several years
traveling abroad meeting with numerous
medical experts but he ended up ignoring
their advice since they all told him the
same thing
he needed to retire all the experts
thought that the job was killing
pulitzer however that was the one thing
he'd never give up since he thought that
his work was keeping him alive pulitzer
did admit that he could no longer
function as before so begrudgingly in
1890 he retired from the editorship of
the world although he still managed it
in absentia from the comfort of his own
home even though pulitzer was supposed
to take it easy his biggest challenge
was yet to come it arrived in the form
of a publisher william randolph hearst
who purchased the new york journal in
1895 a newspaper originally founded by
pulitzer's younger brother albert hearst
went after the same audience as the
world using the same approach to
journalism his strategy seemed to be do
what pulitzer does but do it bigger and
he had the funds to back it up hurst
poached pulitzer's people with better
salaries and he initially sold his paper
at a loss just to make it cheaper than
the world there was also personal
animosity there pulitzer respected
hard-working self-made men while he had
contempt for people like hearst who were
playing the game with daddy's money the
rivalry soon evolved into a journalistic
war that went on for years and
constituted the most shameful period of
pulitzer's life the reality of the
battle was that when his back was
against the wall pulitzer discarded
whatever principles he claimed to have
and descended fully into irresponsible
sensational and sometimes purely
fabricated journalism just to sell more
copies than his rival for his part
hearst had no qualms about matching
pulitzer mover move this explicit and
unrestrained style which is still
pervasive today became known as yellow
journalism and in case you're wondering
the name was derived from the fact that
both publishers fought over the services
of cartoonist richard outcalls who had a
popular comic strip titled the yellow
kid the rivalry reached an unprecedented
height when cuba revolted against spain
and there was serious concern in america
that the u.s might go to war with spain
both publishers realized that a war
would sell a butt load of copies so they
basically turned their newspapers into
fear-mongering propaganda in order to
make the public favor going to war it
was similar to the plot of tomorrow
never dies which would make both
pulitzer and hearst
real-life bond villains to be fair
pulitzer did feel a modest pang of guilt
and started adopting a more restrained
approach to journalism following the
spanish-american war in 1904 he hired
frank cobb as the new editor of the
world and he resisted pulitzer's
attempts to continue running the
newspaper from home pulitzer didn't like
it but he respected cobb so eventually
he relented and handed over the editor
reigns in 1907 he turned the
administrative side of the business over
to his sons and retired altogether
joseph pulitzer died aboard his yacht a
few years later on october 29 1911 age
64. meanwhile hearst continued on his
path unimpeded and eventually amassed
the largest media empire in america
although he did have the benefit about
living pulitzer by 40 years but he is
remembered today as a ruthless
markeraker who made his fortune off of
other people's misery and disgrace
whereas pulitzer mostly rehabilitated
his image thanks to a generous will he
used his money to found columbia
university graduate school of journalism
one of the first and finest in the world
and of course the pulitzer prizes for
journalism which remain to this day his
most enduring legacy
[Music]
you